the other chapter that that really
caught my attention away was
this uh the chapter you have on
mastering violence
and uh and in particular i like i liked
i mean you typed you titled the first
section the best defense is a good
offense
right because i see uh there's a few
channels i follow on youtube i follow
this one channel
more for more for lulz than for actual
practical advice and it's called uh hard
to hurt
and he talks about using like flash uh
flashlights and things to like
smack the home to home invaders in the
face and
various things like this and it's
there's a lot of laughing
in the world when it comes to
self-defense and when it comes to
what they call there's a term for like a
mcdojos
dojos and gyms or martial arts
martial arts gyms that are run by these
fat dudes with ponytails who who pretend
to be
uh [ __ ] what's that action hero's name
from under siege oh uh steven seagal
they pretend to be steven seagal and
aikido their way out of a situation
you defend from a knife etc and look no
that's none of that shit's gonna work
you're gonna get stabbed you're gonna
die
but there are perfectly valid
very useful not just in terms of
self-defense but useful in terms of life
skills
martial arts you can pick up like boxing
like bridging jiu jitsu like mma
krav is really good for disarming people
with knives and stuff like that like i
have
weapons you know throughout my house you
know sometimes it's a hatchet sometimes
it's just a machete or something like
that but
i would not be using a flashlight to try
to take somebody out i mean a hatchet's
a nice tool because it's got one and
that's blunt so you won't kill them but
you can knock them out
or it's got the sharp side which you
know if you need to use it you know you
can use it but
here in canada it's it's it's really
difficult to defend yourself even
even in your own property by a home
invader you're probably gonna have to
deal with some uh plaintiff's claim
against you it's it's it's
it's pretty dangerous here so you gotta
gotta be super careful and that's why
knowing how to defend yourself
regardless of what you use um needs to
be
part of the toolbox that you have around
you as a guy right like you have to know
how to
defend yourself like that like women
love men that are
that that are civilized but can be
lethal
yeah yeah and i always liken this like
the capacity for violence right
you might you might think guys might ask
why the hell would a woman be attractive
to a guy who is violent
hey here we go rollo grifters are up
early this morning
thank you sir
shout out to rolo tomasi indeed i'm and
roland tomasi is going to be on this
show uh tomorrow
at one o'clock pacific time so i've got
a
this is a this is a double one one two
double punch combo for you guys rich
cooper and then roll it to marcia
on my channel i know i've made it now
because i've had these guys on
but uh [ __ ] what was i just saying
bridge i was just i was in the middle of
a thought in the role interrupted me we
were talking about self-defense and
capacity for violence that was it yes
the capacity for violence right
so some guys and particularly even me
when i was younger i didn't
like i was i was always
taught oh violence isn't the answer
you shouldn't get into fights like
because i used to actually get i used to
get into a lot of conflicts as a kid
and that sort of and then and then you
know overbearing mother just tried to
drill that [ __ ] out of me
it was like that's the natural state for
boys is to compete in the physical world
right
yeah and uh and so guys might think well
why why is this like a dhv well i always
sort of explain it as
if you have the capacity for violence
like here's the thing like
you're not a uh um you can't be a
peaceful man
if you don't have the capacity for
violence if you can't actually hurt
somebody you're not peaceful you're just
useless
correct like if you're if you might say
oh i'm a pacifist i'm
like i i believe in peace i don't
believe in war i don't believe in
fighting
but can you fight because if you can't
actually fight then you're just a
punching bag
correct you're just fodder yeah some guy
who can fight
your pacifism is purely based upon him
yeah the problem is is that there's not
a lot of conflict anymore we live in a
very safe world it's it's it's pretty
hard to die like even when you have a
pandemic
you know which is supposedly killing
everybody but yet 99.8
percent of people that get it still
survive um
you know like we live in a very safe oh
let's let's vaccinate everybody let's
wear tampons on her face
and call the masks and hide people away
and scroll away and keep them in
in houses and it's like you know we're
constantly trying to pussify the west
and um well to put it into context there
was
um there was a google study i actually
saw this in a video i think it was
uh a conversation or interview jordan
peterson had but i
included the summary of it in the book
but when women search online
uh for [ __ ] that arouses them
specifically porn and stuff like that
they look for
um billionaire so you know like uh
gray you know kind of like you like 50
shades of grey uh
werewolf uh vampire uh surgeon
uh pirates you know like freaky [ __ ]
like that right like they
like they want guys that that that have
the capacity to put a dent in universe
to
influence right and to also be violent
as well yeah
i mean and and yeah roller's jumping in
here look roller
stop stealing the still in the shell
right we know we know everyone's gonna
pay attention to your comments
yeah we all know you're a lot smarter
than me so just look all right settle
down
uh a capacity for violence translates to
protection provisioning
and parental investment that's exactly
the point right it's
if you have the capacity for violence
then you have the capacity to defend her
yeah and that's what it actually means
it's like they don't think
women don't really think when they see a
guy who's violent they don't think he's
going to use that violence on them
yeah really like although some you're
never gonna like
you know the whole feminized west thing
is trying to
tell guys to be more like girls and to
have girls become more like guys but
you're never going to
wean out you know the evolutionary
component of the dna that exists with
women where they
so where they mate select for men that
have the capacity to
to to protect and preside over them as
roland mentioned you know the
capacity for violence to protect them
should the need be called like
if there's a noise in the house and
you're in bed and myron talks about this
and
you know i had this happen uh it was a
couple months ago the
like i have a home alarm so when a door
opens you hear a little ding ding ding
um the garage uh door wasn't was
unlatched properly like the actual latch
so
it was a windy night and because of the
air pressure it slightly pushed the door
open and then the alarm kind of goes off
upstairs and it's like ding ding ding
she doesn't get out of bed she doesn't
want to go check it out she's
nudging you to go check it out because
that's what's expected of you as a guy
right
so you know like you gotta understand
men and women are not equal like you got
to stop you know consuming this nonsense
out there that
we're all the same and we're equal and
odds we're not we're not because when
the guy breaks into the house
you're the one that's going to have to
go deal with it exactly man
you